c'est devenu une habitude le président
du brésil quitte son palais de
l'alvorada et va parler aux partisans ou
aux journalistes qu'ils attendent plus
bas quand même devant les micros une
certaine distance est respecté et
jaillir ball sonar au persiste et signe
j'espère que ce sera la dernière semaine
de quarantaine de cette manière de
combattre le virus avec tout le monde à
la maison
les gens ne peuvent pas rester chez eux
avec le frigo vide
il enrage environ 70% de la population
sera infecté c'est inévitable c'est la
vérité avez vous peur de la vérité
et quand le journaliste lui demande à
combien de morts il s'attend voyons qui
parle de je ne suis pas croque mort
n'est ce pas en fait ce n'est pas le
président mais les états et les villes
qui décide des mesures à prendre pour
combattre la copie de 19 ce qui explique
un peu sa frustration
cet immense pays de 210 millions
d'habitants est déjà le plus touché du
continent
mais les experts estiment que les
chiffres de cas et de décès sont
grandement sous-estimée et en retard de
deux ou trois semaines parce que le
nombre de tests est insuffisant malgré
des initiatives des ong dans les favelas
il y aurait 15 fois plus de cas que ce
qui est annoncé et c'est inquiétant car
même si les autorités comme ici à rioz
prennent des initiatives pour mettre en
garde la population
on voit bien que tout le monde n'a pas
encore pris cette pandémie au sérieux
jean michel leprince frais du canada à
montréal